let's bring in Jim of course the
Michigan head coach that was fun
yesterday Jim had a lot of fun I really
really enjoy your father oh we are we he
is a treasure you hit the nail on the
head and not only my dad but he's my
next-door neighbor he and my mom live
right next to me and he comes into the
office every day helps me out all the
time and I he's the treasurer's there's
no other way to say it one of the one of
the two greats do you think you could
take him now I would be I think I could
but I would I would not I would not I
was not attempted he he's got old man
strength but there would still be a
little bit yeah there'd still be a
little bit of doubt in my mind do you
have any doubts about your team right
now after that demolishing performance
against Penn State well we don't want to
we don't want to lighten up we want to
tighten up and but I like our team
they're playing they're playing hard
they're playing focused they're playing
confident confident their own abilities
and confident in each other and doing
their job and practice and practicing
really good and so trying to get better
trying to be better today than we were
yesterday trying to be better tomorrow
than we are today
next game will be Saturday against
Rutgers do you find yourself repeating
what your dad probably said to you
growing up yes in most circumstances
yeah I do I do find that more as a coach
or as a parent both both my dad's always
been kind of my go-to guy Dan like I
think everybody needs a go-to person and
I found with my dad and he learned me
from an early age to do what he do what
he told me to do and and I started I got
in the habit of you know whatever my dad
told me to do I would do exactly how he
told me to do it
with numbing repetition I kept finding
from a young age that if I just did what
he told me to do and how he told me to
do it exactly how he told me to do it I
would have success so he's always been
been that person for me that that go-to
person that you know whether it's
professionally personally coaching wise
I just I do what he learned to do what
he told me and he's right most all the
time
will he be honest with you yes I mean
that is there was honest Dave and
there's him as there's Jack horrible I
mean he this is a matter who says what
he means and means what he says
does he come over and watch football and
like last night did you guys watch the
Monday night game no we did not watch
the Monday night game I was working I
was watching I was watching Rutgers and
I don't know if he watched the game or
not but didn't watch the game last night
you basically won I woke up and saw us
all the Tennessee won the ballgame but
that's about all I know
do you watch do binge watch stuff non
sports sometimes Jimmy usually I mean
just I'm just into into the end of the
season and we're watching mom watching
my own practice film or you're watching
the opponent tape and he watched it much
as you possibly can there's so many
situations that you that you have to
prepare for but your wife doesn't say
hey you know what I got a show I think
you'd like it yeah okay she has and
usually I catch you know in the off
season I'll watch some of those I might
have some real real favorites that I
loved a watch and then the World Series
the I came back from a recruiting trip
on the 18-inning game there were 1980
game you know it was like 12 o'clock a
little before 12 o'clock Eastern Time I
think it was a Wednesday night
but I got back I said well kids the last
part of the game you know still might be
going on turned on the TV it was it was
the bottom of the 10th and I watched it
I watched it all the way to to its
conclusion so it'll be that was that was
a that was during our bye week and like
I said I was coming back a recruiting
trip but but yeah TV shows yeah what are
you where some of yours you watch the
like the Netflix and yeah Amazon yeah
I favor show what's your favorite show
dan I would be really interested I I
have too many of them I've I watched
Ozark with Jason Bateman is really good
that's awesome I've seen two seasons of
that okay Bosh is a cop showing I'd like
that I just got done with bodyguard
which is big in in England and the star
of it is gonna be the next James Bond I
believe so it's called bodyguard pretty
good the wire Breaking Bad did you go
through those yeah I did
I thought the wire might be one of the
best I'm one of the best all-time I
didn't watch all the seasons where was
it like seven seasons or no I think
there's some three or four I think there
was maybe five seasons of The Wire did
you watch Breaking Bad oh yeah man it
that that was crazy too and my favorite
is spin-off of the the Breaking Bad
better call Saul Saul yeah I I think
that that's guy to be the back look
that's good we're talking to Jim
Harbaugh by the way the Michigan head
coach I didn't realize the first career
sack for Ray Lewis was against you did
you know that yeah I've seen that
highlight what do you remember about
your with the Colts back then right yeah
yeah that was uh when I was fighting for
the cold she was playing for the Ravens
and I remember that that kind of you
know circulate when they were going
through his career so I feel like I
guess you know it's kind of like kind of
good I guess I'm is kind of kind of
interesting kind of cool yeah and do
your players know y'all downing you know
Pam
with Hank Aaron do your place al dala
dala feel about so on the 715 - hey
Karen but would you want to be
remembered like if if you don't know
that then you don't remember al downing
but you do remember him do you think any
publicity is good publicity I don't know
I don't know I mean I wonder who Hank
Aaron hit his first home run off of
maybe put me in that category I get I
was Ray Lewis hall-of-famer Ray Lewis
his first sack but I don't know it just
seems kind of it seems kind of cool I
guess a couple other things I didn't
know this so when Michigan decided that
you guys were going air Jordan you were
gonna go the Jordan Brand and then
Jordan calls you and this is what 2015
and yes and you didn't think that Jordan
would be calling you yeah there's there
was there was another player we were
recruiting at the time named Michael
Jordan who was an offensive lineman and
he plays for Ohio State now but yes so
at that at that time we were recruiting
Michael Jordan and there was of course
Michael Jordan so I was you know I was
like you know which Michael Jordan is
this Michael Jordan this is the Michael
Jordan so it was that was pretty awesome
when yeah we first took the job here was
there was this the shoe contract was up
and and you know we had to you know
there was there's a lot of good shoes
out there etc but my son Jay came up
with the idea he said you know there's
no there's no Jordan
there's no Jordan football school and
that would be it would be pretty awesome
so I'm a huge fan of Michael Jordan I
played in Chicago in the late 80s and
for the Bears but you know everybody you
know just to be at a game and watch
Michael Jordan take off from the
free-throw line and
slam dunk contest whatever I mean the
way he played was just it was just an
incredible to watch so yeah I was a huge
Michael Jordan fan still AM
that would be awesome will be you know
be affiliated with with one of the
Great's of all time in any sport yeah we
want to be a want to be we want to be
Jordans first school in football so then
he called and said he wanted us to be
that and so it was like it's Tom Cruise
and Jerry Maguire you had me at hello
let's do this you know that's that's
really how it took place don't you I
want it don't you want another piece of
Notre Dame with this team now on the way
you're playing well I mean I think it
they're playing well this is yeah but
it's just I mean it's it never seems
like a good idea to to look too far down
you know ahead of your yourself and it
doesn't doesn't really help to look
behind you too much it really just be
mindful of what's straight ahead and
right in front he and the task at hand
and not be thinking about 20 different
things but be thinking about one thing
and that's you know preparing ourselves
to play Rutgers this week and that's our
that's our task how many can you go a
day without somebody mentioning Ohio
State uh yeah probably
you prepreg gets mentioned once a day
sure think about it absolutely I mean
that's a that's a that's a that's a big
deal around these parts always has been
yeah is it always will be
I'm uh can I ask a request here of if
you beat Ohio State can we get the game
used khakis for the man cave here I
don't see why not
okay that seems fair enough all right
good that's breaking news Jim Harbaugh
will take his pants off for the Dan
Patrick show I do have a Harbaugh
mannequin in here that somebody sent me
like you're like hat and shirt and
glasses so I got a whole mannequin of
you in the man
kind of credo pad with no path well not
not game use pants like I want game used
Ohio State pants and you're gonna be at
the game yeah but I'm not gonna be on
your side though no you're an Ohioan
yeah I mean you understand it right I
understand that okay I do is this gonna
motivate you more the fact that I would
be on Ohio State side it's probably not
okay no probably not going to be
relevant and the motivation for the game
it's our data okay you know it's already
at a high level as they said you know
both both sides it's always it's always
been that way and it is and it always
will be all right all right you know if
you want to reference me in the pregame
speech to the to the boys then go ahead
yeah well Michigan ruined a lot of
Thanksgivings for me coach so I wouldn't
be surprised if Michigan won this game I
think you guys are playing a lot better
but there's still a couple of weeks left
we're not getting ahead of ourselves but
thanks sir
no sir thanks again for yesterday that
was a lot of fun and I I meant what I
said about your father he's a he's a
treasure he's a real treat and I really
enjoyed it I heard you talk about that
and to me not so much not didn't rise to
the level well I get it
I've heard that all I've ever heard that
my whole life my dad is he is he is uh
you know he's a great man he can have a
conversation with my dad here's the one
thing I really kind of envious about my
dad I wish I was more like but I don't
have this quality as much as he does is
you could have a 15-minute or 20-minute
conversation with my dad and you'd walk
away I really know him I really you know
it like him I really connected with him
and where I'm a little bit more like I
don't make the greatest first impression
but I grow onion after some time but
he's got that great first impression and
like when he comes in the room you know
he's in the room I mean
he's got this matter and it's attack
each day with an enthusiasm unknown to
mankind and Ralph Waldo Emerson you know
believed that nothing great can be
achieved without enthusiasm and there's
you know two great minds two great men
both you know think alike and and choose
to live their life with tremendous
enthusiasm that rubs off on you it rubs
off on you when you meet him for the
first time it rubs off on you when he's
your dad
it rubs off on you when he's he's your
coach he's just he instills you with
this positive tremendous enthusiam
affects you every day in a positive
manner that's that's who he is as a
person and just to clarify I do love
your dad and and John's a pretty good
guy too your brother so just want to let
you know that too
awesome yeah and I mean you're getting
up there
you're probably behind John and Tom
Crean your brother-in-law so you're your
fourth on the depth chart right now I
get it I get it but if you beat Ohio
State you're gonna you may go up to
number two you'll never get to number
one but you might get to number two just
in your family
not in the country thank you again coach
had fun
thank you Jim Harbaugh the episodes of
attack each day the Harbaugh podcast
available every Tuesday and I'm on
today's episode listen on demand podcast
1.com he joins us courtesy of the
Continental Tire Coach's Corner
Continental Tire proud to be the
exclusive tire of the Dan Patrick show
no matter where you drive what you drive
they've got a tire for you at
Continental Tire dot-com for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]